- Hello, everyone, I'm Jeff Brock.
I'm the Dean of the School of Engineering
and Applied Science.
We're going by the
moniker Yale Engineering,
just to drive the point home.
This is the Dean's Invited Speaker Series,
which I'm really pleased to inaugurate.
We had the idea that
it would be a good way
to announce our new
strategy to the community
by inviting really affiliates,
friends from industry
that have taken their Yale
experience in some way
and turned it into a
bright, illustrious career
in industry in one way or another.
And our visitor today, Kathryn Guarini,
is an embodiment of this.
She has become a good
friend over a few meetings,
we have some commonalities
in our Yale experience.
Like me, she met her future spouse
while engaged in an
extracurricular activity,
in her case, The Yale Herald.
In my case, I was moonlighting
in a James Joyce seminar.
So be careful which extracurricular
activities you choose.
You may end up reliving them
throughout the rest of your life.
So, I'm also really excited
to have you hear about her story,
her trajectory through her
time working in industry,
and the different twists
and turns that's taken.
But on a somewhat lighter
note, I'll just mention,
she has recently been mentioned
in as some top 10 ranking
in a list of 100 Most Influential Women
that included Taylor Swift,
Simone Biles, Beyonce,
and who's the other one?
(Jeffrey laughs)
Yeah, anyway, so we're in the presence
of some celebrity here
and the School of Engineering
and Applied Science
in our Applied Physics
Department in particular,
thank you Vidvuds for joining us,
generates a lot of celebrity in the world,
and Kathryn is among them.
So we're very pleased to welcome her.
She's gonna give about 30
minutes of presentation
and talk about her trajectory,
and then we'll have plenty
of time for some Q&A,
which I'm happy to host.
So welcome, Kathryn, thank you for coming.
(audience applauding)
- Hi, everyone. Thank you so much.
It's really great to be here.
I graduated in 1994,
which sounds like a really,
really long time ago,
I'm sure to all of you.
I was in Morse, I was an
applied physics major,
and I really have wonderful memories
of my time here at Yale,
so it's always nice to come back.
And I'm gonna share with
you a few things today.
I have, let's see, three main topics,
and really this is meant
to be sort of a teaser
of topics that I'm more
than happy to talk about.
So when we get to the Q&A,
if there's anything that
you'd like to hear more about
or ask me questions, then
I'm happy to discuss.
But I wanted to first talk a
little bit about my career.
What did I do when I left Yale
and how did that transpire
into a series of different opportunities?
I think Yale really prepared me well,
but I had no idea where I would go next,
and I will tell you a little
bit about how that played out.
And then talk a bit about
technology and transformation
in my role at IBM.
I spent 24 years in different capacities,
largely trying to drive innovation
and transformation leveraging technology,
and I'll give you a little bit of a feel
for what that has looked like for me.
And then I wanna spend a few minutes
talking about the other
aspects of being a leader,
particularly a leader in
the technology industry.
It would be great
if we could only talk about
science and engineering,
but in reality that's fun and important,
but not sufficient to really drive impact.
And so I think there are
a lot of other aspects of leadership,
leading teams, driving execution,
managing crises, and others
that I learned on the job.
And I think there's a real opportunity
to think through some of
that perhaps ahead of time
and be better prepared than I was
as I got into some of these experiences.
So let's start with career first.
I imagine some of you
think of a career ladder
or some idea of some long-range plan.
I always admired those
people who were really clear
about what they wanted
to do when they grew up.
And I never knew.
In fact, while I was an
applied physics major,
if you had caught me in my first
or second year here at Yale,
I probably would've told you
that maybe I was going to be
a political science major,
or an Italian major, or art history,
or maybe I wanted to go into journalism,
or who knows, all sorts of things.
And then I ended up
focusing on applied physics
because it was hard, and I
liked solving hard problems,
and I liked figuring things out.
My grandfather was a math
teacher here in New Haven,
taught at the public schools,
Hillhouse High School,
for many, many years.
And for as long as I
can remember as a kid,
he thought doing math
was the best thing ever,
and he made me think that math as a tool
for solving problems was fun.
And so when I got to actually apply it
to solving problems like in physics,
I thought that was fun too.
So after I got my degree
in applied physics,
well, actually before I got my degree,
I actually got a chance
to work as an intern
at Hewlett Packard out in California.
And this was summer of 1993,
so it was sort of the
heyday of Silicon Valley.
And a professor here, Robert Wheeler,
who I think is now retired,
but he connected me to
one of his former students
who was working at HP,
and that's how I ventured
out across the country
and spent the summer working
in industry in the tech world.
Taking measurements in
a lab, writing code,
trying to figure out what you do
with an applied physics
degree in the real world.
But what an experience
being in Silicon Valley,
and I decided to go back.
So I ended up going to Graduate School
at Stanford down the road from
HP in Palo Alto, California.
And being a part of the
Silicon Valley community
at that time was really stimulating.
I went back to HP for another summer.
I did an internship at
Advanced Micro Devices, or AMD,
who is now a tremendous
leader in the industry.
They were playing second
fiddle at the time to Intel
in semiconductor technology
and manufacturing,
but I got a chance to see what it was like
to take some of this science
that I learned in school
and actually apply it in the real world.
As a graduate student,
I worked with a professor
named Calvin Quate.
He was about my grandfather's age.
I was among the very last
of the students he had.
He looked like Einstein,
big, white, crazy hair.
He was the co-inventor of
the acoustic microscope
and the atomic force microscope, or AFM,
that some of you may know about.
And at the time,
everyone was talking about
the end of silicon scaling,
Moore's law,
that you wouldn't be able
to pattern using light
and using traditional optical
lithography any longer
to shrink the transistors
and scale the microchips.
And therefore, we wouldn't
get faster computers,
we wouldn't be able to
have better electronics,
and there's lots of worry
at the time about this.
Now, world has changed,
and we still have faster computers
and powerful cell phones.
But the time, everyone was thinking about:
How can you scale the way
how small something you can pattern?
How do you make better transistors
that can actually turn off
when they get to the dimensions
around a few atoms thick?
And so that was what I did,
and I got to get in a
lab, build transistors,
use these scanning probes
to do parallel patterning,
emit electrons from a probe,
build transistors, build chips, test them.
So it was a hugely
interesting experience, right?
Really trying to learn how
to actually build things
and demonstrate value that
the industry was looking for.
So when I finished my degree,
I came directly to IBM,
and then I spent the next 24 years at IBM.
So a long time, but doing
so many different things.
I started doing technical research.
So my first six or so years,
I was working in a lab,
and I was taking some of that experience
I had in graduate school,
and doing internships,
and actually applying it to what IBM did,
which was to actually build
semiconductor technology
for their system's business,
building microprocessors
building all the chips
that were in the competing game stations,
the Nintendo chip, the Sony,
the Microsoft Xbox chip, and so on.
They needed to have high
performance technology
to deliver that.
And so I first was in the research lab
experimenting with new transistor designs,
new structures, new materials.
And then I moved into the
development space, which is:
How do you get these to yield reliably?
How can you build them at scale
and ensure that we have a business
that is gonna be productive?
And then I got a chance
to move around the company
outside of that semiconductor
and research development space
because I wanted to know
what the rest of IBM did.
And I'm gonna tell you
all a little bit about IBM
because I didn't know.
All I knew was this little research world
because as a graduate student,
I'd read papers from researchers at IBM,
and I thought I wanna do that.
But I didn't really know what
the rest of the company did.
So I deliberately moved
outside the Research Division,
got a chance to work in development
of our microprocessor design.
I was managing a large global team
designing microprocessors.
Again, I'm not a circuit designer,
but I was leading a team on that.
Moved into product management.
How do we launch net new products?
We wanted to bring a technology.
The mainframe technology had been around
for 50 years at that point.
We wanted to bring that technology
known for reliable, secure,
highly available computing.
We wanted to bring that to new workloads
and to new clients that had
never used a mainframe before.
How do you do that?
Well, we actually
leveraged the open-source
operating system Linux on
the mainframe technology.
We launched a new brand
we called LinuxONE.
We went out and talked
to clients and said,
"How do we get you to use this product?
What is inhibiting you?
Is it skills? Is it user experience?
Is it functionality,
performance latency, et cetera?"
So bringing that back
and then working with
our development teams
to design the next
generation of that product.
It's a completely different
type of experience for me.
How do you price it?
How do you go to market?
Where's the product market fit?
Who is the competition?
It's a completely different
set of questions and answers.
And then I came back to
the Research Division
after having been outside of
that for almost a dozen years,
and I worked as the
Chief Operating Officer
for the Research Division.
IBM Research has 3,000
researchers, largely PhD,
mostly doing very deep technical work,
some exploratory, more academic life-like,
and some very closely collaborating
with our development teams
and that whole spectrum.
I've been around for 75
years, this Research Division,
but we were worried about
going the way of Bell Labs
and other industrial
research organizations
that aren't around anymore.
And so my role as the COO was:
How do you make sure we're relevant?
How do we increase the impact
but not lose that very special capability
that was able to have Nobel Prize winners
and to have very, very high recognition
for the innovation in
the Research Division?
And then I spent the last
2 1/2 years as IBM's CIO,
which is the Chief Information Officer,
and I'll tell you a little
bit about what that role is
because again, I didn't really know.
I didn't really know what
the role was all about.
And it's different in
different organizations.
But suffice it to say, large organization,
big set of deliverables that
the company was relying on.
And I got a chance
to use a lot of the skills I had developed
over the course of my career,
to figure out how do you
solve both technical problems
but also some of the
execution and leadership
and other aspects of leading in innovation
when you have high stakes.
Because at that point, all IBM
employees and all IBM clients
were then relying on the CIO team
to deliver the IT and the
capabilities to do their jobs.
So, I can go forward here.
Let me just tell you
real briefly about IBM.
So it was founded in 1911,
so it's been around a very, very long time
and it's changed a lot.
You see at the bottom of the chart
some of the things it's known for,
from punch cards, to computing machines,
helping to land people on the moon,
certainly well known for that.
Watson beating "Jeopardy!"
in 2011 was a proud moment.
I started to kind of understand
what natural language processing
and question-answering systems could do.
And today, the the
flagship product from IBM
is called Watsonx,
and you may have seen some
advertising about that recently.
But what's interesting when
I'll tell you a little about
the IT or the CIO role is the
size and scale of the company.
There are 280,000 employees at IBM,
it's like the size of a small country.
But it does business in 170
plus countries of the world,
which means you have to deal
with different cultures,
languages, regulatory
requirements, laws, et cetera,
and time zones when you're managing
and supporting that community.
And then the size and
scale of the business,
it's about a $60 billion revenue annually.
And it has three main
portions of the business.
It still has what's legacy infrastructure,
hardware business, delivering systems.
Was largely what I had
started in that space.
It has a very growing software
portion of the business.
And the big piece of that
was the acquisition of
the company Red Hat.
It's known for open source
enterprise software.
And then there's a consulting business.
So technology and business services
that IBM supports as well.
And so as the CIO,
I was the global person and
organization responsible
for delivering IT to that IBM community.
So large number of people,
lots of geographic spread,
and working with clients in
all these different industries.
So this is a quick picture
of what the CIO organization
at IBM is responsible for,
and I'll point you to this middle section.
It's called Digital Workplace Solutions.
It's mostly what people
associate with IT or a CIO.
You get your workstation,
your laptop, mobile device.
You get on the intranet that
can get IT help or support.
And those certainly are the things,
one of some of the things
that I and the team was responsible for.
But little did I know, the stuff on top,
the Business Applications
that actually run the company
were actually the lion's
share of the investment
and the complexity that
we were responsible for.
So running payroll
systems, and procurement,
and real estate, and supply chain,
all the HR systems, et cetera, finance,
how do you close the books.
All these applications, over
4,000 enterprise applications,
that we needed to run,
IBM successfully need to be
reliable, secure, scalable
that when a client has an issue,
they can get in touch with
and get response times immediately.
How do you modernize that environment?
How do we take advantage
of new technologies?
How do we improve the
experience for our employees
and for our clients,
that we transform this
and reduce how much we're
spending while we're doing that?
So that was this challenge
and getting our arms around
that and maintaining it.
And then, of course,
we're responsible for the infrastructure
on which that is all run.
And because IBM's an IT company,
I wanted to be an early adopter
of all IBM's technology, right?
So just as we develop a new server system,
or a new piece of software,
or we have a way of partnering
with a set of strategic
technologies in the industry,
I wanted to be the very
first to use that technology
so that we could demonstrate the value.
If it can work for IBM at our scale,
it can work for any one of IBM's clients,
and then we can also provide feedback
to our development and our
product teams to make it better
so that IBM could grow as a business.
So we had both the responsibilities
sort of at the back office
to support the company,
but also to be out there leading edge
to make sure that we're taking advantage
of IBM's technology
'cause you can imagine
if you go to a customer
and you say, "IBM, we're
focused on hybrid cloud, and AI,
and Watsonx, we've got this
great stuff, you, CIO..."
Because IBM actually sells to CIOs
in the industry of banks, and
retail companies, and so on.
"We've got a solution for you?"
What do you think the first
thing that they're gonna ask is?
Do you use it yourself?
Does it work for you?
And if the answer's no, we
lose all of our credibility.
And so it's really important
that we be out there in front.
It means we're taking risk,
that means we're being an early adopter
and actually co-creating.
All right, so I wanna talk a
little bit about technology.
I'll just let you read
this little cartoon.
It's one of my favorites.
Everyone's so excited about
ChatGPT, and it's wonderful.
I mean, how exciting that we
all have AI in our hands today,
it really is,
but that's not the same as
applying AI or any technology
to large-scale enterprise environments
'cause I have to worry about data privacy
and confidentiality.
I have to worry about
scale and repeatability.
Is it trustworthy?
What data was it trained on?
Can I explain the results?
And so I want to use
all of the technologies
in the very best there is,
but I need to be very
thoughtful and responsible
about the applications of that technology.
And it's not technology and innovation
just for technology and innovation's sake.
It's about: What problems are we solving
and what value are we delivering?
So I always like to start
with what are the issues
or what are the concerns on
the minds of business leaders
in an enterprise?
And so here are some, there
are, of course, many more,
but huge pressure at an enterprise level.
And I saw this at IBM and I
saw this in our clients, right?
Most of our clients are coming
to a company like IBM saying,
"Help us reinvent
ourselves using technology;
new business models, new
ways of going to market,
new ways of developing products."
Productivity is the word of the year,
of the decade, perhaps.
Most CEOs, so the leaders
of these companies,
are telling us that what they
care about is productivity.
And what that usually translates into,
how can I be more efficient and effective?
How can I get my workforce
to get more output for a given input?
How do I get more things done?
And so AI and technologies
are certain a piece of that,
but it's also new ways
of working the hybrid
or remote working model.
It's labor shortages, it's
skill shifts, it's a huge focus,
and technology can play a key role.
Cybersecurity is a huge concern.
Massive number, and frequency,
and severity of cyber attacks today
that are very, very costly
not just in dollars,
but reputational cost, and
time, and business value.
So we need to protect against that.
Sustainability has become top of mind,
probably should have been
for a very long time.
But it now finally is clear that all of us
and businesses are playing a
role in impacting our climate,
and we need to take responsibility
for being very, very thoughtful.
And technology is both a contributor,
as well as a potential solution in:
How do we address some of
the pressing challenges
around sustainability?
Geopolitical risks,
this is rising threats.
This is supply chain
vulnerabilities and much more.
And finally, public health,
and we've just been through a pandemic.
But it's not only infectious
diseases, it's mental health.
And it's so many other
aspects of public health.
Care about that at an enterprise level
'cause it's our employees,
it's our clients,
and society at large.
And so if you think about these are a set
of the problems that we see in
front of us every single day,
technology and innovation can play a role
in addressing this.
But it's not just about:
How many applications of AI do you have?
Interesting, but more
important about the, "So what?"
What are you doing with
it that's meaningful
and impactful to the company
and to the organization?
So I'll highlight just three technologies
that I think are important today.
There, of course, are many, many more,
and these are in different
levels of maturity.
I'd say hybrid cloud or
cloud computing today
is very much a mature and
available set of capabilities,
but still in its infancy in
terms of wide-scale adoption.
And by that, we largely mean
the legacy world was all
these distributed data centers
all over the world.
When I took on the job of CIO,
there were 74 different data centers
where IBM was running workload
for our internal use all over the world.
I mean, I think about it like,
"How do I get my arms around that?
Where is everything running?
How do I secure it?
How do I think about the sustainability?
What's the carbon footprint of all that?
How do I manage latency and
performance and user experience?
How do I modernize something
that is that fragmented?"
And so by moving to a true hybrid cloud,
and by that we mean a
combination of on-prem, private,
and public cloud,
not one public cloud answer only
'cause that typically
locks you into a solution
that may not be any better
than you were before.
But having some flexibility
to be able to move workloads
across different environments.
If I maybe have a change in
the requirement from a client
or from an employee,
I wanna be able to have more flexibility,
which I didn't have in the
old legacy environments.
We've moved a huge
amount of IBM's workload
into this more flexible environment,
and we're seeing tremendous benefits
in terms of how quickly we
can deploy applications,
how much money we save,
and frankly, the carbon
footprint piece as well.
AI, I mean this is the
hottest topic today,
I am sure everybody here
is talking about it,
thinking about it, using
it, which is great.
As I said, it's really
about the responsible use
of that technology.
But we have a number of
enterprise applications,
in particular we've used robotic
process automation, or RPA,
to automate manual tasks.
This isn't about displacing workers,
it's actually about getting
off of their plates.
A lot of the more mundane tasks
and freeing their time and energy up
to do higher value work,
which is important, and needed,
and frankly valued by
our employees as well.
We had a number of applications,
like automating HR and
IT support using AI.
So you don't have to wait on a call center
and worrying about what
hours is there someone there.
We're used to this, sorry,
in the consumer world.
But many enterprises don't have it
because they worry about
security and privacy
in many of their aspects.
But at this point, if I wanna
transfer an employee at IBM,
or do a salary increase,
or do a whole host of other HR tasks,
they can almost exclusively be done
through digital assistant
chatbot AI technology.
It can be done 24 hours a day,
it can be done with inline
language translation
if you're in a part of the world
and you don't speak English,
you're not comfortable.
It gives you a lot more flexibility,
and we just applied some
very similar technology
to providing that IT support.
And quantum computing.
So Yale also is very,
very big in this space.
IBM has invested.
This is what we have today,
but I think there's still opportunity,
very much opportunity into the future
on how do we leverage
new computing technology
not to take over,
not to replace traditional
classical computing,
but to be able to solve some problems
that simply can't be solved
with the technology that we have today?
It's very exciting.
The work that IBM,
in collaboration with
a number of partners,
is advancing this capability very fast,
and we're seeing that now
people can actually solve
some really interesting problems,
starting to see quantum advantage.
The number, this is 433 cubits
or bits that are available
for quantum computation today
with a commitment by the end
of the year will be 1,000,
and before long tens of thousands.
I mean, that's a term...
I honestly, truly didn't think
that that was gonna be
possible in our lifetime.
It's an amazing level of progress,
but it's interesting on the technology.
But then what do you do with it?
So the applications, the use
cases in quantum chemistry,
in finance, and optimization
are really compelling.
And the network of universities, startups,
and large Fortune 500 companies
that are starting to explore
what quantum computing might do for them,
it's very exciting.
There's also the fear
factor, which is, "Oh, gosh,
when we have large
scale quantum computing,
this will be able to break
traditional public key cryptography."
And that's true,
but there are new cryptographic algorithms
like lattice cryptography
that are robust against
large-scale quantum computing.
But then that takes us back
to our cybersecurity focus,
and what do we do to make sure
that we're really prepared
for quantum computing,
take advantage of it,
but we also protect
against some of the risks
that any technology brings?
All right, and then my last
section is about leadership,
and one of my favorite cartoons here
because I think it's so telling.
Most people think, "Oh,
great, you're the CIO?
So you just tell everybody what to do."
That must be pretty
straightforward, right?
Jeff, you're the dean, right?
You just get to tell everybody
what to do, right? Really...
(Kathryn and audience laughing)
And that would be nice,
but the reality is, and you all know this,
leadership is messy, and it's complicated,
and it's challenging in many ways.
And so I thought I would highlight
some of the aspects of leading,
whether you're leading an IT team,
or a product development organization,
or research community,
or launching net new products
that you need to think about
that are outside of the bits and bytes,
outside of the science,
but are critically important to success.
So the first is, when you're
driving these projects,
there's a whole host of
things that we do as leaders
that need to be thoughtful about:
What does success look like?
What are we really trying to achieve?
And how will we know
we're making the necessary
progress to deliver?
So there's the strategy
aspect, the project planning,
the budgeting, the prioritization,
what guardrails do you have in place?
What metrics and measurements,
what governance do we have?
And this stuff is not
all that straightforward.
It depends a lot on the team,
and the priorities, and how,
but hugely important to success.
And again, it almost doesn't matter
what you're trying to do.
You're trying to deliver
a new mainframe system
to the market,
you're developing quantum computing,
you're trying to create
an innovation through AI
and delivering it to
280,000 IBM employees.
You have to be clear on
what does success look like
and how do you ensure
that you can deliver on that commitment.
But there are always risks, always.
So how are you thoughtful and proactive
about identifying what those risks are?
And how do you minimize those risks,
but also prepare for the eventualities
of when something goes wrong?
'Cause it always does, right?
Have all sorts of crises
stories that I could tell,
but I will tell you one that
will probably make you laugh.
We moved to a new mail
system a couple years ago.
And as the CIO,
it was one of the things
that I was responsible for,
one of many things,
and didn't think it would
raise to the top level
of my focus and attention.
But when you move 280,000
employees to new mail system
and the system goes down
and they can't access their
email for upwards of two weeks,
that's a crisis.
Made the paper.
I had to record all
sorts of communications
to the entire global community,
to talk to our CEO on a daily basis.
We had to put an action plan.
It wasn't something we
could just switch a button
and be back.
There were technical challenges,
there were leadership challenges,
there were communication challenges,
there was root cause analysis
that we needed to understand.
And then once we got
ourselves out of that crisis,
we needed to make sure that we were clear
how we would prevent anything like that
from happening again.
So how do you learn from that experience,
and not just Kathryn learning
or not just the leader
of the project learning,
but the organization at large, right?
How do you help the
organization to be better
for any of the issues and concerns?
And then perhaps the most important thing,
and if you even remember
one thing from my story,
it's all about the people
because you can do great science
and you can have interesting project plans
and crisis management proposals,
but it's all about the
people that you have
to get your projects done, and to inspire,
and to drive innovation,
and to do delivery.
And those people, they
require handholding,
and support, and
inspiration, and leadership
in order for them to be most effective.
How do you build effective teams?
How do you build a a
multidisciplinary set of capabilities,
people with different expertise
who understand the different
cultures, and geographies,
and laws, and disciplines?
And how do you help them to
work together effectively
if they have these different
perspectives and experiences?
How do you reward or
incent the right behavior?
How do you provide performance
feedback effectively coaching
and you manage your team effectively?
All of this is sort of not
taught in school, I would say,
but so important to the success
of any of these projects.
In my experience, what
we tend to not recognize
or even prioritize enough,
even from those of us who
have risen through the ranks,
who have a PhD, and vice
president experience,
and leading large organizations,
because I'll tell you the first
time I had a 500-person team
and we're trying to
build a microprocessor,
and you have billions of
billions of transistors
that all need to be connected together
in a way that you can tape this out on us,
specific date, 18 months from now.
Well now, you have the complexity
of managing that schedule,
you have the technical
hurdles that need to get done.
How are you gonna have the right latency,
and performance, and so on?
You have the personnel aspects.
Do you have the right
skills and capabilities,
roles and responsibilities?
Who's gonna be making the decisions?
What happens when all of
a sudden, six months in,
there's a new opportunity or challenge?
There's a competitive issue.
There's a technical issue.
You have to have these kinds
of experiences and skills
in your pocket,
so you can pull them out and respond.
And if you don't, you learn on the job,
and you find mentors and you
find others who can help you
to be effective.
But for sure that you don't do the things
that I've been talking about with science
or with engineering alone.
It's super important.
I think the credibility
of understanding the
science and engineering
to many of these leadership positions
has been very important for me.
But to couple that with
some of these other aspects
of leading, executing, and driving teams,
and the inspiration part,
because in the end you're
gonna have hard things,
there are gonna be hard days,
and projects, and challenges,
but you need to have the
team with you, right,
who are excited and
about coming in every day
and working as partners to
try to solve these problems.
That goes a hugely long way
into the overall success.
So the very last chart before
we open it up for questions.
You've heard about a lot of things
that I like to talk about.
I decided a few years ago during COVID
when we were all stuck at home
that I would start a blog
and write about some of these topics,
whether it's leadership,
and work-life balance,
and what it looks like to be a woman
in a largely male-dominated
hardware technology space,
or science and innovation, et cetera.
And one of my favorite things
is when someone will say,
"Oh, I read that and I
agree, or I disagree,
or I had a similar experience,
or I'm also struggling with that,
or my husband also does the laundry,"
or whatever the story happens to be.
So it's been a great conversation starter.
And as Jeff said, my
husband also went to Yale,
so he still happens to
be wearing a Yale shirt
in this picture.
He was in Solomon right near here,
and we met working on The Yale Herald.
So we have got a science and
he's a social studies teacher,
and so we got different
sides of the brain.
And we have three
children, two in college,
one in middle school.
And it's been an adventure, right?
Lots of fun, lots of learning.
And my favorite thing about
being in the technology space,
as I said, it's hard, but
it also, it's always...
There's always something new to learn.
There's always something new to learn
about the science and technology,
but also in all those other aspects
of leading projects and driving execution.
And it's been a wild ride for me.
I've got a chance to learn
over many, many years,
and I look forward to
learning more going forward.
So with that, I will open it up.
(audience applauding)
- Great, thank you so much, Kathryn.
Okay, great, we'll get some seats.
I also do the laundry, by the
way, just full disclosure.
So I want to open it up for questions,
but I have a couple questions
of my own, if I may.
The first is Yale...
prepares us in various
ways for various things.
What would you say is
the thing you remember
about your Yale experience
that has helped you the most,
and what do you wish you had learned here?
- Interesting question.
- That they missed.
We missed.
- So one of the most
pivotal experiences I had
was as a leader on The Yale
Herald or the weekly newspaper.
And not just because I met my husband,
although that was also pivotal,
but being in a leadership role
with people who didn't have to...
We weren't getting paid, right?
Nobody had a job and was
really worrying about so much
on their resume.
But it was because people felt like
they wanted to be a part of the team,
and that they felt valued,
and that we all made it fun,
but we also cared deeply about
the quality of the output.
And I think that experience,
perhaps more than anything else,
is something that I took forward
into other leadership roles that I had.
And so that's something
I absolutely remember
and just working with brilliant people
and being in a community
of smart and motivated,
ambitious but collaborative people.
That's something I really
valued in my time at Yale,
and I've looked for,
and one of the things about IBM
is you're working with people
who are deeply smart, and motivated,
and not so different perhaps
in the community here.
So absolutely have enjoyed that.
What do I wish?
So I learned so much
from a technical perspective
in the applied physics.
Applied physics was, and I think still is,
a fairly small department,
and I was deliberate about that,
and I stayed in an Applied Physics Program
in graduate school as well
because I liked that basic science,
but also applying it
to real-world problems.
I sought the industry
experience and reaching out.
I would say I didn't feel
like there was a lot of...
I got lucky that I have a professor
who connected me to somebody,
but I think the opportunity to
learn about what kind of jobs
and what kind of opportunities
exist out there in the world.
So like what you're doing
and inviting people in to share that,
I think that's great.
I didn't feel like I had a
lot of that when I was here
and I couldn't really imagine
what life would be like after,
and so I just kept going
and then it worked out.
- Mm-hmm, yeah, it is a true unicorn here,
the applied physics major.
I don't know there...
How many applied physics
majors are there in the office?
- Anyone?
- Ah, there we go, okay.
Okay, great.
Yeah, I mean that's really interesting.
So we wrestle, and the
institution wrestles, I think,
with the question of the kinds of how much
we should broaden the
training of undergraduates
to include the things that you mentioned
as these really key skills
that you are developing
kind of on the job, right?
So do you have a sense of if
we were to think about new ways
to develop the curriculum
that would prepare people
for some of the things
you didn't learn here but
maybe wish you could have,
is there kind of a list of key things
that you would suggest we think about?
- I think there are.
I think there are frameworks and models
for some of the things
that I've talked about.
And I think there's an opportunity
to both learn about them,
sort of the book learning of
it, but also to practice it.
And so I know you have
experiential courses,
leading teams and projects.
I'd say there's very little
of having a hard problem
and going off and thinking
about that by yourself in a room
that I've experienced in
the professional world.
A lot of this is team-based learning.
It's figuring things out together.
It's taking advantage of all
these different perspectives.
So I think finding ways
to get that experience
while you're a student
so it doesn't feel so foreign
when you get into the working world.
- Yeah, yeah, I agree.
And then I guess I have one more
and then I'm gonna open it up.
So we are really eager to
bring kind of like this,
bring some of the
knowledge, and experience,
and even the sort of technology
and technology awareness
that exists in industry
into how we think about
teaching our students,
how we think about collaborating
in terms of our research labs.
What do you see as the
sort of positives of that,
but also some of the pitfalls
that universities need to be aware of
as we sort of embrace technology
that exists in industry?
- Yeah, I think there's huge
value of bringing it in,
and making it relevant,
and seeing kind of this real-life,
tangible what's going on,
and how do you get your arms around it.
But I think the pitfall is
you wanna get so enamored
with one particular technology, right?
ChatGPTx is not gonna
be the end-all, be-all
for the rest of your careers.
It's more about how do you understand the:
What led to that innovation?
What are the key components of it?
How do you understand when
new technology emerges?
How do you take advantage of it?
Because there'll be next year,
five years from now, 10 years from now,
it'll be something else.
And so it's really, I think
it's important to be relevant,
and to be connected,
but not to get so enamored
by whatever it is today.
Because the technology
in the business world
is changing so fast.
It will certainly be
different as you progress.
- Good. Okay, any questions
from the audience?
Yeah, right here?
- [Audience 1] Sure.
- Oh, we have a mic 'cause...
There you go.
- When you made the transition
from a sort of research,
sort of PhD role, to
a more businessy role,
I guess there were a lot of
skills, as you sort of said,
that you sort of maybe
didn't have or had to learn.
To what extent did you feel
like you had to be really
proactive about going out
and learning those
versus really learning them on the job
or just sort of like using
the sort of experiences
to guide you?
- I did a lot of learning
on the job, I would say,
and I think that is pretty typical.
Certainly at IBM, I can't
speak to every other company,
but I think in tech that's pretty typical.
In technology,
even people outside of, say,
the research and development,
we don't have a huge number of pure
sort of MBA business management leaders.
The fact that the CEO of IBM
is a PhD electrical engineer, right?
Not an MBA, not a...
I mean, he is a super smart businessman,
but his technical training
is in engineering.
And that's sort of the
ethos of the company,
and so it wasn't like I had
to go get an MBA or I had to,
and I took various classes
and I found value in that,
but much of that was learned on the job.
And in fact, my first management role,
the first time I was
leading a team of people
and they had to do performance reviews
and be responsible for their success.
As is typical, you get
promoted into those positions
because you're good at
your other job, which I...
This is something every
company out there does,
and it's typically a mistake, but,
"Hey, you're really good at
being a technical contributor.
We'll make you a manager."
And all of a sudden,
you have people in management positions
who have no business being
in management positions
because they may not actually be that good
at the guidance of a team
or the leadership of a team.
They may be just really,
really good individual contributors.
Now, some grow into it, right?
Some actually embrace it
and want, but others don't,
and then that's a disservice
to the people in their
organization, right?
They just suddenly now have somebody
that is looking for the power or the...
So for me, when I got that
first leadership position,
I was actually super excited about it.
I wanted that and I valued that,
but I also knew that I
didn't have the experience.
Suddenly, I was managing people
who had many, many more years
of experience than I did,
who had...
Sometimes difficult to manage, right?
Especially in the research community,
notoriously sort of
independent-minded, as you can imagine.
And I didn't feel like
the role of the managers
or my role was particularly valued
even amongst the leadership in research.
That, like, I was disappointed by that.
I said, "This is really important.
I wanna do a great job at this."
And they're like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah,
just keep doing your research."
That was how I felt.
I don't think that was actually accurate,
but that's how I felt.
When I moved into other parts of IBM,
particularly into development teams,
the role of the manager,
it was super important.
'Cause suddenly, you
couldn't get a project done.
You couldn't deliver our
chip design on schedule,
keeping your team motivated.
If you didn't have managers
who were really equipped
to lead these teams effectively,
but also have the technical credibility
that the team would listen,
and so I really liked being a manager
in the development organization
because suddenly that
role was really important.
And I was playing not only
a people management role,
but also a project management role.
So responsible for the
delivery of the project.
And I found that really rewarding.
- Yeah.
Either way, yeah.
Circle around.
- [Audience 2] Did you ever
experience impostor syndrome?
And if you did, how
did you deal with that?
- Yeah, that's a great question.
So impostor syndrome, for
those who haven't heard of it,
is very common that people feel like,
"Well, I'm not deserving.
Why am I in this position?"
So yes, most of us in in
leadership positions have.
Particularly when I became the IBM CIO.
So suddenly I was in a C-suite
position at the company,
and I thought,
"Why me?
Right, why am I in this role?
Do I deserve to be here?"
And it's very natural, right?
It's, I think many of us,
and it's particularly common among women,
question whether you are deserving
or whether you are up to the task.
I think the biggest advice I have
is that you're in it for a reason, right?
Nobody gives you a job
like this to be nice.
"Hey, Jeff, wouldn't it be nice?"
I mean, It doesn't happen,
it just doesn't happen.
It's too important to the
business, to the company.
Nobody's getting token jobs.
So you gotta bolster your
confidence a little bit to say,
"Of course, it's deserved,"
but then you have to earn it too, right?
So for me, it's about,
"Okay, get over that,
but then what do I need to do
to make sure that I can
do a great job, right?
What do I need to be effective?"
And it doesn't mean knowing everything,
or being the smartest in the
room, or knowing all aspects.
I showed you that CIO portfolio.
Look, I took the job, I
didn't even know that, right?
I literally didn't know
what I was getting into.
I had been in many other
parts of the company,
but the reason why our CEO
decided to put me in the role
was suddenly they had somebody
who had developed products,
who knew the IBM organization,
who understood how to lead large
teams and drive innovation.
So I was coming with a
different set of experiences
than my predecessor and others
who had been in that space before.
And I was focused on:
How do I bring that,
how do I bring that value
that I was selected for,
but also how do I learn,
how do I surround myself with people
who can fill in some of those gaps
and have expertise where I don't?
And not be afraid to
ask a lot of questions.
I ask a lot of questions
and it's not because I'm
trying to test somebody else,
but because I genuinely am
curious and I need to know,
and I want us to explore and
figure things out together.
So I think those are
all sort of techniques,
but it's not unusual.
I was just telling Jeff I
just got appointed to a...
my first public company corporate board,
and I said, "Well, this
board is so impressive.
There are Nobel Prize winners
and there are people who
have been leading all the..."
And my first reaction is,
"Why do they want me on that?"
(Kathryn chuckles)
And so I still have it, I still have it,
and I think it's only natural.
I think it's good that you can continue
to be somewhat humble
and not think that you're
deserving of everything.
On the other hand,
kind of have to straighten
your spine and say,
"I can do this, and I'll add value,
and let me figure out
how to ask a lot of questions and learn,
but also figure out what
my unique value add is
and lean into that."
- [Audience 2] Yeah. Thank you. Thanks.
- [Audience 3] Hi.
It's related to the question
about transition from research
to management and business jobs.
I guess apart from skills
that are to be learned,
what can you recommend on us
to prepare for it mentally?
Is there a mindset change that 'cause...
I guess I'm a PhD student,
and as a PhD student, it's a lot of time,
it's to make things
work right on the edge.
- Once.
- [Audience 3] And I take fun of that,
but that's probably not the
correct spirit in management.
So when I feel that
things can be done better,
but there's compromise to make,
when you feel this way,
do you feel uncomfortable?
And do you think there's a mindset change
that we can prepare ourselves?
- Yeah, that's a great question.
Yeah, it certainly is different.
When you're doing research in a university
or even in the research
community at a company like IBM,
there's a bit of a luxury
in that you're not looking necessarily
at trying to build repeatable products,
you're not looking at
trying to scale a solution.
You're trying to typically
drive innovation,
invent, demonstrate something is possible,
and boy, that is exciting, right?
Something that's never been done before.
You're trying to show for the first time
and to demonstrate that value.
So there's so much great
experience from that,
and not everybody can do it.
Obviously, there are people who just,
they're not programmed that way.
They're not as excited by this invention,
and this innovation,
and this brand-newness.
But it is different when
you move into a space
where suddenly you're trying
to deliver something at scale,
where repeatability, and reliability,
and performance, and
security, and privacy,
like all these things become paramount.
And even if you have something
that's been demonstrated,
it's amazing,
it may not have any place over here.
And that's true, right?
So I think one of the
interesting things for me
when I went back to the Research Division
after having been outside
it for quite some time,
I had a completely different
mindset than I had before.
So now I'm saying, "Why
are we doing this?"
In some cases, not everything.
Like, "This is never
going to work, right?"
And I had to check that too
because part of the role of research
is to explore avenues
that may or may not be
commercially viable.
So that's okay that some
portion of the portfolio
is pushing the envelope.
We can't always know where it will go.
So you don't wanna predispose, or limit,
or stop doing things just
because there's risk.
But there has to be a spectrum,
and that was one of the things
that I was focused on in research
is to look at a portfolio of projects,
some that are in this riskier element,
which is okay to not always
see the commercial viability
in the early days,
and some that have a lower
risk and more alignment
to the product portfolio
commercialization and so on.
And as long as you're
deliberate about that,
and you acknowledge it,
and you're clear-eyed,
I think that's fine.
But there's a difference.
And if you do everything over here,
I don't think the community,
I don't think a industrial
research lab will survive
if everything is so far afield
that they're a shot in the
dark and super high risk.
But if everything in research
is so close to product
that it's a guaranteed home run,
then you're probably just an extension
of the development team.
And it's probably not truly the role
that a research
organization needs to play.
So that spectrum or portfolio,
I think, is really important.
- [Moderator] One more.
- Great.
We have time for one more.
Oh, there we go.
- [Audience 4] So I was curious,
since you've been at
IBM, I guess, 24 years,
and it seems relatively rare
that maybe someone would
stay at one spot for so long,
especially in tech.
One, did you ever consider leaving IBM,
and were there different
points in your career
where you really kind of
checked in with yourself,
or consulted mentors,
or even just how you thought about
kind of reaffirming the decision to stay
and what value you
might've actually derived
from actually being in one
spot instead of moving around?
- Yeah, really good question.
It turns out that there are
not only a few people at IBM
who stay 20, 25, 30, 40
years at the company.
So it's not that unusual,
although at large,
like the average tenure
for most people in jobs
is four years in the country right now.
So it certainly is strange on that side.
If I were doing the
same thing for 24 years,
I would've gotten bored
and left immediately.
So the nice thing about a
company like IBM, it's so big,
it has so many different
aspects to the company
that I had the pleasure of
having a dozen different jobs
over the course of 24 years.
So that was a real benefit to me.
And why, because I had a network
of people that I had worked with,
I understood the processes, I
know how to get things done,
I understood our technology portfolio.
I could take some of my
experiences in one area
and move it to the other,
and then all of a sudden
I had a network of people
I could reach out to.
So in development, suddenly
we had this technical problem,
and I could call up my
friends, and colleagues,
and former employees from
my research days and say,
"Drive up to this development lab,
we need your help," and so on.
So I think that there were
sort of intangible benefits
of being at the same company,
even though I had the chance
to do all these different things.
I was deliberate
about going after doing
different things, though,
I mean, I would say there
are not just a few people
who come to IBM Research
and stay at IBM Research,
and it's a large...
3,000 researchers, it's a large community,
but there are 280,000
people at the company,
so it's a much larger company.
And it was the most surprising
change people said to me was,
"Why are you leaving Research?"
And I'd been there about six years,
and I made a deliberate choice
to go learn about what
the rest of the company.
And that's what allowed
me to kind keep learning
and keep having these
different experiences,
which, for me, was what
kind of kept it interesting.
- Great. Can I sound you
out on one last topic-
- Sure.
- Before we adjourn?
You mentioned one of your blog posts
was about what it's like to be a woman
in a sort of male-dominated
technology field.
And I just wonder if you
could give us a sense of that
and some pointers perhaps
for folks in our audience?
- Yeah, there's no easy answers.
Unfortunately, not enough
has changed, in my opinion.
It wasn't so unusual
when I was back at Yale
to be among a few of the women
in applied physics classes
or in engineering classes.
And that continued in my
PhD program at Stanford,
that continued when I joined IBM Research.
There was never a line
at the women's bathroom,
so there's benefits.
That continued when I moved
into hardware development, right?
Working in the semiconductor world,
working in the systems development,
and then even in the
product management side
of that hardware.
So hardware tends,
still, to be less diverse
than other aspects of
engineering and applied science.
So my disappointment
is that not enough has
changed in the last 30 years
as I would've hoped.
The good news is I think
there's a lot more awareness
that we need to tap into a
larger segment of our population
for a lot of the important
innovation and opportunities.
They're lucrative jobs,
they're exciting challenges.
We want all diverse perspective.
There's so many good reasons.
There's truly a business imperative,
not just it's the right thing to do,
but again, we're still not
seeing such a dramatic change.
I didn't experience overt
discrimination or bias.
I really didn't.
There were times where I felt awkward
or I felt just disappointed
that I was the only woman in the room
and sometimes I was the leader in the room
as the only woman, which can again,
feel a little bit, I'd say uncomfortable,
but you get used to it, I'd
say, a little bit over time.
My experience is just to not
be afraid to sort of speak up
when I need to,
even if that takes a
little bit of practice,
and then speak up for
others as well, right,
when I see that there are women
that maybe are sitting not at the table,
or are not being heard.
Stereotypically, but actually in practice,
I have seen plenty of times
where a woman will say something
and it's not really recognized,
and a man will repeat
it and everyone says,
"Oh, what a good idea!"
And I will often say, "We
heard that five minutes ago.
It was that good of idea,
let's make sure we go back to so-and-so
and hear what other ideas she has."
So I think it's on all of us,
but particularly for those who
are in leadership positions,
to look out for circumstances
where traditionally the woman
gets asked to take the notes,
or send out the agenda,
or do the things that are
the extra work when...
That's reasonable sometimes,
but that those sorts of responsibilities
should be passed around.
So as a leader, I think
there's more we can all do
to call that out
and then help to move things
forward in a positive way.
- Good, well, Kathryn,
thank you so much for
being here with us today,
you're a tribute to Yale.
And we're very pleased
you're able to share
your story with us here.
And thank you all for coming.
Look forward to more Dean's
lectures in the future.
Join us again.
(audience applauding)
(pensive music)